je ne crois pas du tout à la
transposition du résultat de l'élection
présidentielle
sur chacune des circonscriptions ça
n'aurait pas de sens à vos à dire qu'on
aurait que des députés en marche
d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite je
n'ose imaginer que notre pays soit notre
assemblée soit constitué de la sorte au
soir du 19 juin donc pour moi ça ça n'a
pas de sens donc le coup du moins de 5 %
ça arrivera peut-être je n'en sais rien
mais sur certaines circo et être
absolument pas dans tout bien évidemment
ensuite sur le risque de s'abîmer
vous savez on ne fait pas que des
élections ne se présente pas uniquement
lorsqu'on est certain de gagner pour la
bonne et simple raison c'est qu'on n'est
jamais certain de gagner ce que je veux
dire que c'est qu'il ya aussi des des
territoires de conquête sur lesquels on
doit être présent et puis on doit offrir
une alternative comme je disais tout à
l'heure entre un vote
macro nist qui ne représente pas à pas
vraiment une offre politique crédible
puisque c'est de droite et de gauche et
puis en face c'est simplement des
extrêmes je trouve que en tant que
républicain on a une vraiment cette
responsabilité de proposer à bulletin
alternatif pour nos électeurs qui sont
aujourd'hui un peu perdu
l'élection je ne suis pas en train de
dire comme certains que qui prétendent
être élu premier ministre à l'issue des
élections législatives qui n'a pas plus
de sens d'ailleurs non mais au delà du
parti bien comprendre qu'on est aussi
dans la représentation de forces de
droite et du centre avec nos partenaires
de l'ue dit les centristes également qui
avec lesquels nous avons des discussions
sur l'ensemble des circonscriptions en
france
tout le monde dit toutes les analyses
sociologiques disent que le parti est
majoritairement de droite ça serait
quand même un comble de ne pas pouvoir
proposer
quasiment partout donc cette expression
de droite pour les législatives donc moi
je travaille en ce sens en tant que
président la fédération départementale
ici dans le maine-et-loire et je sais
que tous les présidents font de même
partout en france parce que je vais rita
blanc c'est important moi je ne peux pas
me résigner à cette extrémité
extrémisation des des expressions de
vote entre l'ama cronje les extrêmement
oui c'est une quinzaine entendu ce
chiffre circule et de deux personnes qui
se lançait dans l'aventuré avec beaucoup
d'espoir derrière la candidature de
valérie pécresse à l'élection
présidentielle qui aujourd'hui sont sur
le reculoir on va dire les choses comme
ça je ne crois pas de un phénomène
massif
on voit bien que certains ont fait le
choix plutôt de de ce2 se reprend j'ai
du côté du président sortant
probablement pour sauver leur poste moi
j'ai une autre vision de la politique
qui consiste à porter ses portes et ses
valeurs défendre ses convictions et pas
forcément sur des terrains acquis
d'avancé parce que la politique c'est
aussi un combat de un combat d'idées un
combat de valeur donc je crois qu'il y
en aura suffisamment de candidats pour
défendre ses valeurs de la droite et du
centre les 12 et 19 juin en tout cas moi
je travaille en puissance
mais à la caisse si certains
journalistes qui nous pose la question
de savoir si on a une réflexion sur
l'avenir du parti il faudrait vraiment
être vivre sur une autre planète pour ne
pas comprendre qu'il ya eu un message
qui a été envoyé le 10 avril à notre
part notre électorat donc bien sûr qu'on
a on a cette réflexion sur la
refondation du parti ou plus globalement
la recomposition des des valeurs de
droite dans notre dans notre pays qui
encore une fois toutes sont majoritaires
en france toutes les études le montrent
donc bien sûr qu'on doit avoir c'est là
aussi cette responsabilité de mettre les
choses sur la table et puis de redéfinir
une offre politique peut-être un petit
peu un petit peu moins uniforme qui est
que sanaa était par le passé avec
différentes sensibilités c'est
l'histoire de l'ump depuis 2002 vous
savez l'udf et le rpr qui acceptent de
fusionner pour créer ce grand parti et
faire obstacle à l'arrivée de l'extrême
au pouvoir qu'il s'agisse de l'extrême
gauche ou de l'extrême droite ça a
marché jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
encore jusqu'en 2022 donc nous avons
cette responsabilité nous sommes les
seuls à pouvoir assumer ça parce que
nous ne nous feront pas de négociations
avec avec l'extrême droite en france par
exemple on oublie de le dire au moment
où le ps se est en train de se fourvoyer
avec une alliance avec la france
insoumise c'est à dire l'extrême gauche
ce qu'il ya de pire dans l'extrême aussi
bien nous nous personne n'en parle mais
les républicains sont restent sur leur
socle et n'ouvre aucune négociation avec
l'extrême droite je m'étonne que
personne ne relève 7 cette différence
avec le parti socialiste par exemple
[Musique]